the dm's are probably crazy right yeah
multiple dudes oh my damn think a lot
there's no shorties there are there are
there are a few shorty shooting shots
there are like sit on my face or i want
to sit on your face type [ __ ] sit on my
face
my face is wild that would be wild but
no it's the other two i want to see this
guy say and sit on my face oh wait gay
guys are coming after oh
tons how much have they offered uh bro i
haven't i haven't got to that you've
never got a big offer from like some
saudi arabian prince i never got nah i
never got you never got the [ __ ] on the
glass table no never got i know about
that [ __ ] happening though but i never
got that i never got that deal why
because you know girls that had that
happen oh yeah talk to me no you want to
know about that yes yes oh that's their
business
oh my god
but tell the story that's real though
right like people don't think that we're
being hyperbolic that's a real thing
though no no girls really go out like on
yachts and get [ __ ] on yeah
like 100 okay you're you're you're in
you're the only just for that 100 just
for that and then he's like okay that's
something that's all i didn't want to
[ __ ] the girl because he's already done
it so meant like so many yeah he just
wanted that to be like i did that the
power move i can make you [ __ ] on a
glass table that's it yeah and you know
what call me yeah
i would [ __ ] i'll do it [ __ ] on the
glass table and you're going to buy for
like a mill or a couple mil like a
couple yeah
100 000. bobby first class on the eddie
hart oh my god
or emirates whatever that's fire hello
you've been on emirates first class no
no crazy oh my god it's like yeah it's
like it's like you went out there
wait a second
it wasn't that kind of content what kind
of content was it it was workout [ __ ]
100 i promise did they make you squat
first yeah i did some squats but they
didn't make me do anything no one made
me doing this workout [ __ ] you did say
workout [ __ ]
probably [ __ ] a few times when i was
there but it wasn't anything to do with
anything else okay just saying i was
sitting in bathrooms but you know that
you know i don't know what they got in
that bathroom maybe they were [ __ ]
who knows dude maybe i'm somewhere on a
only fans thing i don't know there's
probably a bunch of dudes strapped to
something
yo you're a dumbass
yeah that's so good
you're a [ __ ] idiot bro
oh i love this [ __ ] this is the dog okay
okay okay
okay of cause you're you're the
interesting cross-section between the
workout community and the youtube like
influencer community yeah of the girls
that we see you don't have the name
names okay of the girls that we see like
these like famous kind of like
influencer chicks right yeah yeah how
many of them are getting paid to get
their [ __ ] cracked open and cleaned out
just just out of curiosity
it's crazy because like i don't even i
think some of them just do it like not
even so much to get paid like some do it
because it's like
they just want to what do you mean by
that i just know a few people who have
cleaned out a few and there was no money
involved wait so they just go they fly
out there i'm talking about the girls
you're talking about dubai [ __ ] no not
even dubai but just like how many of
these girls that we see right because
what i'll give you is another scenario
another friend of mine won't say his
name but he basically was like yo
there's a billionaire like service
and like if you're trying to smash
something and you're a billionaire there
are these girls that will do it but
these girls
are like
celebrities yes you're just like
famous and this is only for like the
billy club but we're talking about
victoria's secret models not the one
not that one
not that one which one are we you know
anyway
you know i think we're on the same page
yeah okay okay um but like
but other ones but other ones got it
okay and so so so my buddy told me about
this and i was like that's like a real
thing he goes yeah i'm like why did the
girls do it he goes the money's just too
crazy to not do it and low-key those
girls if they're single they're probably
going to be [ __ ] guys like this
anyway we're not talking about scumbag
like losers we're talking about like
successful billionaire business people
like that we all know yeah and that
person will probably stay quiet so so
everybody's quiet so i'm wondering how
many of these influencer chicks that we
think they're making all their money
selling 50. how many of them are out
there
selling
i mean i feel like they wouldn't even
want to tell me i think i probably know
like two
who does who do stuff like that
and they talk about it
i mean like reluctantly but what do you
say well you're just like yo just be
honest why were you in montana
montana i mean they're just trying to
get a bag i don't even blame them you
don't right i don't blame it man would
you do it would i do it super hot check
queen of england goes listen cure me of
covid
cure
i mean like what's the bag like 250 cure
me of covert 250 yeah you got to go down
on her suck it out um
something goes
out of the queen of england
i mean i feel like i do it just for the
story
yeah i don't even need a 250 the story
is just like you could have got the 250
brad
i'm good i'm good okay yeah so you would
do it 100
[ __ ] it would you do it yes yeah it's
like yes would you do it for the 250 or
you do it for just a story no i need the
250 because that [ __ ] probably tastes
like parchment for me it's the 250 would
be part
250 be for the travel time like i don't
like the whole i hate that [ __ ] don't
waste these days yeah i hate the whole
like you know like there might be a one
layover or something like a connecting
flight i hate that she can't do it i
hate it dude i literally won't fly
somewhere if it's like a layover why i
just don't i just i hate i hate like i
love being here and i love doing this
and i took red eye i was like this guy's
wild and i love meeting you and everyone
here you guys are dope as [ __ ] i just
hate the process like prior to the plane
and then getting off the plane and the
whole like put the mask on all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's like yeah [ __ ] off
yeah i just don't like that it's i
didn't like it prior to all this [ __ ]
and it just got a hundred times worse
yeah
yeah i think we're done with the math
[ __ ] thank god i mean you're in l.a so
it's a little bit different but it's the
king of that [ __ ] yeah it's like where
they're like
you